some people on the internet like to
think of me as you've seen this before
they they call me johnny knoxville's
older
brother or something who is johnny
knoxville there you go perfect okay
that's a good start
three yeah perfect
[Music]
be quiet your microphones all be quiet
okay seriously okay sorry sorry
my name is george moats and as you know
it's my job to protect the american
hamburger but i can't do it alone so i'm
already grooming my future replacements
would you please welcome my son my
prodigy
macbooks
my knees
maybe we should rehearse okay wait i
need to like stress hey mac you're on
the show
wow you know what we're gonna do right
make some hot dogs
why is this no we are going to make
hamburgers and do what eat them
right we're also going to study some
hamburger history oh how important is
hamburger history
very important hang on my stomach's
ground when you hear that whoa
i'm excited to be able to show you how
to make a hamburger how to appreciate
the hamburger all right
okay every like people appreciate wine
right
yeah they spend all this time talking
about fine foods
how to appreciate art right yeah
what are you making fun of it it's great
have you ever had the desire to make a
hamburger like how deep is your desire
not so deep kind of deep well i love the
burgers that you make they're always so
good so i guess that i've
always wanted to like try to make one
for myself
i suddenly couldn't make hamburgers
could you make one
maybe by the end of this video oh yeah
there you go buddy look right there
don't look at him look over here right
there
yeah we've been working with a ham
bigger than me
okay pork chop geez today's episode is
special not just because he's here
but because we partnered with common
threats
common threads is a non-profit that
provides healthy snacks for kids
but also cooking instruction and that's
important so how can you help
hit that donation button hit it the goal
is to raise 50 000 bucks
right 50 million
not 50 million 950 million the goal is
to raise 50
000 bucks so that common threads can
fund summer programs for 200 kids
so in the spirit of giving back i would
like to pass
yelling yawning so in the spirit of
giving back i would like to pass on some
of my burger knowledge
to mac to me yeah you we're about to go
through are you ready for this one a
hamburger obstacle course
that involves trivia cooking
and a prize at the end oh prize whoa
like prizes right
so much you ready yes okay let's do this
i don't know come on we can do better
than that let's get better then
you ready let's do this there we go
the first part of the hamburger obstacle
course trivia
see how well do you know the hood's got
to go on great yeah it does
how well do you know hamburger trivia um
exactly we're going to find out
here we go ready okay my cool little
cards here see that
okay ow
round one round one how well do you know
dad
oh gosh hmm ready how many burgers do
you think daddy has eaten daddy sorry
how many
burgers
here we go how many burgers do you think
dad has eaten his whole life
your whole life whole life i'm going to
give the answer
of 75 000
no it's a bit much 40 000
the answer we're looking for is closer
to 20 000. oh okay
so that's still a lot of burgers next
question ready
okay name dad's least favorite condiment
ketchup this is easy i got that
this is too easy but the questions get
harder now ready
yeah here we go round two burger history
okay name the beef stuffed dough
that actually may pre-date the burger by
over 50 years
oh wait um
i actually know this one it's the brock
nailed it okay that is just i just want
to say right now
i'm a proud papa i'm a proud papa right
now because he remembered that
round three harder questions
okay what state was the cheeseburger
invented in
i really want to say oklahoma but i
feel like it's why you're so close to me
i'm listening
listen um i feel like it's
yes
massachusetts no i don't know where it
was california oh oh girls like
california really no
that's not gonna happen the most
important question what is the air speed
velocity of a cheeseburger laden swallow
north african or european oh for all you
monty python nerds out there nailed it
let's have a little trivia on the
cooking instructions let's do this ready
are you okay you okay they hit you
you okay yeah we're gonna make the
burger
that you love the burger that i make for
you all the time the burger i want to
show you how to make
stop that mac what is that
serenity now okay the burger i'm going
to show you how to make
is the burger you already love to eat oh
which one's that
the lacey faces lacey face oh not the
lacy face
the lacy edge burger from
illinois to make a lacy edge burger what
do we have here
buns meat salt butter cheese that's it
why is the butter here
because you toast the bun with it bingo
let's do that first ready
yep okay toast the bun first okay we got
some butter we got a
but you hear that that's the sound of
bun toasting happening
we need a couple of tools here right
what do i have in my hand here
um a scooper a scraper and a spatula
yes which one comes first um the
probably the scooper the scooper there
you go so
i'll do it but first things first i'm
just showing you that's right here
see this yeah scooping ice cream but
we're skipping beef instead right
yes i make it sort of flat in there
right but that's it i'm gonna press it
in there i'm trying to make it so it's
enough it's a portioned
a portion piece of meat there see that
see that yeah i got it don't look at
the floor look at me it goes right on
the flat top just like that right
okay now the next thing is what you
smash it no
softening spatula comes out
now what's happening is we're cooking
this little patch at the bottom of the
ball right
right you gotta follow it's very
important right roll it over so the
patch is now facing up
you understand got it so it won't stick
to the spatula
you got that and we're gonna we're gonna
press pretty much straight down
right so then kind of roll off to the
side without
actually picking up spatulas see
you want to see some meat come out from
underneath that see what's going on
there yeah
that's it we're done what's what's the
first thing you notice by the way you
see that
do you think they're it's getting crispy
around the edges
it's getting lacy who would have thunk
wise guy look at the lace is the lace
yes the lasso
so it's ready to flip you know how do
you know what's wrong with the flip
oh what um
i'm not tired don't fall asleep that's
very important watch don't just go
the laziness listen to me you know just
go
[Music]
you don't just go okay
you have to actually watch watch watch
with the plane carefully see the lace
there
yeah okay carefully
get underneath it and flip it over see
that
wow cheese on the flip right yeah cheese
on the flip
lace look at that lace
onto that bun goes our finished burger
what's that beauty oh my god dude it's
exactly the way you
like it it's messy wow look at that oh
my god wait can i eat this now
first show the camera look at that
beauty okay let me see that again
i'm gonna eat this one
it's a good oh
you're going to make your own oh that's
right
let's switch spots okay okay go that way
oh god
oh oh it's so hot what's that
he's got to go this way to be in the
frame ready no wait wait first thing i
have to do
prepare the bun right
[Music]
right no yeah dude
what comes next beef yeah so make the
beef watch your hand don't bring your
hand up
so you need some beef right you got to
get try not
there you go but now it kind of molded
it and it molded the burger you want to
get some
is that good i'll make sure you i'm
going to set you out for success man
let me do it dad
sounds so awesome give him about 20
seconds you want to create a patch
right where you going there okay there
you go okay
there you go now what that's right smash
time
oh whoa whoa look at this oh my god
oh god roll roll there you go
okay pretty good left off carefully
okay okay that's good now lift up
carefully
oh nice work buddy pretty good
pretty good for the first wow that was
actually i'm impressed
that was very impressive max great
here's the thing about smashing oops
once you smash the first time you can't
go back and re-smack what's happening is
the heat is going up through the meat
and it's rendering the beef fat and at
this point if you smash it again
you would just push all the beef fat out
you want to keep that in there it keeps
it kind of moist
if you smash it again right now you have
a dried out burger if you smash at the
beginning before
the rendered fat is actually happened
then you uh you get away with the
smashing thing
if you smash it after that all the
moment meat oh
you smash it after the fact all the fast
goes out yeah
it goes away all right so i set up my
seven seconds okay so it's pretty quick
ready so listen very carefully scraper
carefully get under there
check it out like get you really
there you go it's going to stick ah get
under there there you go flip it over
nice work what goes right next what
happens next
um the cheese cheese cheese
cheese cheese juices yes
i'm a cheesy hamburger i don't want
burnt chicken
okay i think we're ready to go what do
you think it's done um no yes
what do you do next what's the next step
mac
oh um put it on the button there you go
nice oh where you going over there no
no no no no no
fast there you go dude
wow i think you pretty much lacing it up
there buddy yeah
oh nice what's my how about on here
again what's that
what's this the crown oh
you see crown do you think did you say
crown i did yeah that's exactly what
it's called
oh yeah top of the bun people it's right
you hear that oh wait my 13 year old son
who has more than you about hamburger
buns
oh you want to you want to switch
switching
you're going to go over here and eat
this burger and i want you to tell me
how you did
how'd you do what do you think
wow you seem impressed with your own
burger
i think so actually i think you did a
good job i think you did really
seriously
you know what this means you can make
your own your hand the samina mm-hmm
what about the whole thing one bite
yeah i'm being very mad at you oh
that's good what that means right bye
i can make a burger no that means i'm a
good teacher
you have any teachers like me at school
back
no you're
way too strange thank you that was the
first time he's ever done that right
yeah you've never smashed your paper
before that was pretty well and he
nailed it the first try which i mean not
to disparage my son at all but you can
do it too
you can do this it's pretty easy sorry
looks like there he goes and we lost him
i'm going back
home come back you want a
for that proud get a prize really yes
you ready for this one oh gosh
it's your very own nope
not a special sorry it is your very own
i'm so excited is it a spatula
it's a scraper it's a blue skull oh
i got my own scooping very own scoop
buddy
this looks used it's vintage let's just
call it
not used
thank you i see you appreciate your
prize back
yeah i very much do this is this
i'm sorry i'm just gonna pull it
together man this is the greatest
honor that any scoop master could ever
get
i am i am honored with this okay
i'm gonna bring this down to my grave my
gravestone will say
he made a burger
that's pretty good he made a burger
listen
very important donate to common threads
hit that button
make a donation see you next time right
he won't be here next time what
oh okay
hit the button and make a donation
[Music]
that's nice thanks no no no no it's